the once peaceful village of kalemlar
is now a burned-out ring farhadukhtan
says he'll risk his life to save his
parents
he succeeded but their family home was
lost
within minutes the flames surrounded the
village and our home while i was trying
to rescue my parents
i took my parents out but the speed of
the fire was so fast
blazers came from all directions i
hesitated for 10 seconds
and then i was surrounded by fire the
house that i had lived in my entire life
turned to dust within 10 minutes
the first news of the wildfires came
from managar
in the southern antalya province and
found by the strong winds
they soon spread to surrounding villages
including kalimlar
but not everybody made it out alive
a german woman and her turkish husband
who had called this village home
for more than 20 years were killed
we just fled when the flames were coming
over us but that couple went home to
take their things
then we didn't hear from them at all we
kept asking where they are
their phones were off then on sunday we
found out that they left home but could
not get through the fires surrounding
the house
we found their bodies leaning against a
wall they were completely burned
and those who survived are now without
homes and livelihoods
nearly 60 of the 100 houses in this
village
have been destroyed or heavily damaged
with little to return to but rubble
more than half of the people here have
been forced to flee
among them is ibrahim ursbai whose home
of 40 years
perished in the flames my name is my
name
when the fire broke out i immediately
tried to rescue my elderly mother i
barely survived
my home was ruined by the flames our
farms also got burned we lost all of our
livestocks
now i don't even want to look at my
ruined house because it is giving me an
unbearable pain we don't know what will
happen and what we will do
since wednesday more than 130 fires
have broken out across southern turkey's
coastal regions
most of them are under control but the
provinces of moola
antalya and asparta are still trying to
put out flames
government says it will compensate
people for their losses
and support is pouring in from all over
the country
and abroad with the firefighting planes
coming in from croatia
spain russia iran ukraine and azerbaijan
but so much work still needs to be done
for people to once again
call wiz like kalam that home
[Applause]
resource al jazeera managed